[Music]
after watching this video you should be
better prepared to list the four traits
an idea must carry in order to be easily
understood and shareable to identify the
force psychological aspects that help
motivate people to share content and
ideas with others and to outline a new
content idea and test it against the
traits necessary to maximize social
sharing impact let's begin lesson 2
building content that is inherently
shareable now when it comes down to
driving social sharing there's truth to
the fact that sometimes you're going to
create a piece of content just on a whim
without putting much time or thought or
energy into it and it's just going to
take off sometimes it's about luck it's
about the right content at the right
time launched in the right place and
picked up by the right person but it's
not all about luck and it's important to
understand that when it comes to social
sharing there are certainly some things
that you can do to stack the deck in
your favor so I want to walk you through
a couple simple concepts these are four
traits that help intrinsically make your
content more shareable a lot of these
are inspired by some of the writings
that you'll find in the book made to
stick by Chip and Dan Heath which is an
outstanding read in understanding again
sort of the psychology and that the
intrinsic qualities of content or
concepts or ideas that really helps make
things inherently shareable so I want to
walk you through these four traits and
give you a couple sort of examples of
seeing it in action so that you really
understand what it is kind of play off
them with the way you produce and
present your content the first is the
idea of keeping it simple complex ideas
are difficult for people to remember and
that makes them hard to pass on if
someone can't understand and explain
your concept to someone else after the
first time they hear it or the first
time they're exposed to it that means
it's not going to be simple enough to
have that true and intrinsic shareable
quality so you want to make sure that
you're going for that goal of a simple
idea that you're taking the time to test
it on
couple people call up a friend call up
your mom and explain it to her once and
then ask her to explain it back to you
and if she's missing pieces or she can't
quite put it together that's sort of
your your clue or your trigger that you
need to break it down a little bit more
to make it easier for everybody to
understand now a great example on the
simplicity front is Dollar Shave Club
it's a super simple idea it's basically
a web-based subscription and delivery
service grown on the very simple idea of
quality razors super cheap delivered to
your door way less than you pay now and
you see this carry through in the
advertising style that they put together
and in the content they put together you
can see buying razors sucks let us send
them to you
great razors delivered for a buck a
month and then when they decided to
target Emile's it's well the super
simple out of his and hers and they're
exactly the same because what's the
difference it really doesn't matter if
one's pink and ones blue so they play to
that very very simple idea even the name
of the company Dollar Shave Club makes
it crystal clear what they do and that's
part of what has made the companies such
a viral hit is it so easy for people to
quickly explain it to someone else and
say hey there's this new product I'm
buying it I love it here's why it's
great so keep in mind simplicity means
you can break it down to its very base
level super fast and the message still
stays the same now the second thing that
we want to look at is does it spark
emotion because emotions are one of the
single most powerful driving forces in
social sharing so if you can strike a
chord now specifically if you can strike
a positive or a humorous or you know
something kind of happy mode that's a
surefire way to help increase social
sharing and we've seen from study after
study and I could have put tons of
screenshots up here of all sorts of
different studies saying that the higher
and emotional score especially if it's a
positive emotional score the more likely
it is to be shared by other people so
especially if you're going to be playing
on the storytelling side and we've got a
whole series on storytelling here with
and simply learn as well if you're going
to play on that side there's high
emotion stories and those high end mode
concepts really do a great job of
helping to push the sale now a great
example of this on the emotional front
with Disney's show us your ears campaign
any of the Disney worlds or Disneyland's
is familiar with the concept of the
simple hat that has the Mickey ears on
it put your name across the back and
there's millions of different styles for
them so Disney basically asked fans to
upload pictures of them in their Mickey
ears or just of their Mickey ears and
said they would donate $5 per upload to
the make-a-wish Foundation which is a
program that helps children that have
life-threatening illnesses get a chance
to live out their wish and for a lot of
those kids the wishes going to Disney
World
they prompted 220,000 Instagram pictures
to put up I could have posted legions
and legions of these of people taking
selfies of people pulling the ears down
off the shelf and you know posing them
somewhere and putting the picture up and
they didn't usually they didn't always
just put up you know the single hashtag
that was put together you can see in
this last example you know loads and
loads if you know Disney loved Disney
merchandise use Disney bound all sorts
of different ones and so it spreads and
it really takes hold because it's one of
those things that people have a lot of
wonderful positive memories around
another thing that we can look at and
ask ourselves is is it unusual because
moving outside of the standard
expectations of content that's one of
those things that makes a huge
difference in catching the interest of
people if you're the twenty-seventh
person or the 5,000th person to write
about the same topic or to put together
the same story you know offer the same
product people just don't care on the
same front but if you can find a way to
put a new spin or a new twist on
something that tends to catch people's
eyes so a great example of this one is
TOMS shoes who did a day without shoes
campaign and basically they invited
people to go for a day without shoes and
to post pictures of themselves barefoot
to raise awareness for how many children
and how many people in the world do not
have access to shoes and they said for
every picture that went up and that you
know got tagged with that they would
donate a pair of shoes to someone and
traditionally tom has always donated one
pair of shoes for every pair that's been
purchased so it was a way for people
that
might not have the 40 or $50 to buy a
pair of Tom's to still get in on you
know sort of the good and on the sharing
it prompted over 290 thousand pictures
to come pouring in from over 30
different countries and again it was one
of those things that stands out when
people are scrolling through their
Instagram feed or you know someone's
looking at what's going on in a snapchat
story you don't always expect to see
those barefoot pictures unless it's
someone you know on the beach doing that
foot shot pedo themselves standing in
the sand so it's the type of thing that
stood out a little bit and really got
some extra sort of oomph and some extra
sharing from people and then the final
one that we want to ask ourselves is
will people risk their reputation on it
and this is a huge part of anything that
takes place in social sharing because
anytime you're asking someone to share
your content or your story they're
attaching their own name to it and that
means that they're attaching the implied
credibility they have earned with their
audience so if they say hey this is
something really great and people click
through and hate it that damages the
credibility and it means the next time
around people are going to be a little
bit less likely to listen to them so
that credible nature is something we
have to keep in mind that the
bait-and-switch content of looks like a
regular wall but you'll never believe
what you know happens when they turn the
light switch those types of sort of
clickbait that lead into just useless
content that isn't even remotely
exciting people have lost their
tolerance for it and they're not likely
to take the risk of clicking through let
alone turning around and sharing it with
someone else so it's really important to
ask yourself when you're trying to get
someone to share something if it's going
to be the type of thing that bolsters
their perception among their peers or
the damage is that because credibility
is really really a critical part now
great credible example is pretty much
any version of unboxing videos and
consumer reviews that we see popping up
so most of the box services Birchbox we
mentioned Dollar Shave Club barkbox all
of these different ones they encourage
you to take a picture of your unboxing
and you know to post it somewhere and
there's always a send a friend discount
code that if they try it they get a
discount and you were in the money back
pretty much any type of these
campaigns that focus on customers
sharing their experience or you know
sort of a usage video or consumer
reviews all of those helps cement the
credibility of a product and all of them
give people a way to share something
that they've discovered and that they
enjoy and that they are convinced other
people will also like so encouraging
that type of sharing tends to be really
really effective now if you only learn
one thing through this series it's that
I want you to keep in mind that you will
not be able to control content sharing
it's absolutely impossible you can't do
it but what you can do is enable it you
can make it more likely and you can
influence it you know how people do it
and what they're likely to share one of
the big areas of focus that we'll have
during this particular training module
is the psychology of social sharing
again understanding those traits that
are intrinsic to the content but also
understanding how people tend to react
to concepts and ideas and what makes
them feel a connection to something just
enough that they want to turn around and
share it with other people and again
it's important to have these ideas in
the back of your head because well we
all tend to focus really well on the
content that we're an expert on that our
company does or the you know related
lifestyle wives or topically wise to
what our company might do sometimes it's
easy for us to lose focus on things from
the consumer side of things so I want to
walk you through some of the different
things that help motivate people to
share one of the first ones that we
especially tend to see happening with
sort of hobbyists and influencers is the
concept of knowledge and this is
basically that people love to be
identified by other people is that one
person that you can turn to for advice
or input or concepts this is what drives
hobby blogging thought leadership and
people that reviews movies or products
or services being able to enable that by
giving them that experience or that
understanding or that exposure is one of
the ways that you can help motivate
people to share the content that you've
put in front of them now another thing
tends to drive people to share on the
psychological front is the idea of ego
people love to be the first one to have
the the newest or coolest thing around
or to have some type of special access
or privilege so one of the ways to
appeal to ego driven shares and we tend
to see this happen a lot within the
influencer realm people that really
again like to be that that sort of
recognized an admired voice within their
topic or within their industry is to
offer them some type of early access to
give them previews or maybe some type of
behind-the-scenes insight and this can
run the scale in a couple different
places it can be something that's
offered to everyday consumers you know
maybe you're you're doing something
that's time-sensitive on you know
snapchat or maybe I'm Twitter that you
want those instant chairs to take place
or maybe it's the type of thing that's a
little more focused and a little more
planned out that you give a limited
number of people that early access or
the preview so that they can be the ones
to break the story now there's also the
idea of passion we've talked a lot about
emotion and that positive emotions
really play a heavy role in how people
react to our content but also in their
willingness to pass it along to other
people when it comes to social sharing
when it comes to being motivated by
passion or by emotion this tends to be
people who just love a topic so much
that they'll happily share any relevant
content so again we see this in highly
emotional verticals so if you do
consumer packaged goods and you're
appealing to moms or you're appealing to
Brides or you're appealing to any subset
that tends to already have emotion tied
to it intrinsically this is one of those
ways that there's a lot of potential to
reach out and really tap people to play
to the thing that they really care about
and are passionate about now there's
also the more tangible concept reward
and people being motivated to share
based on what they might get in return
this might be a tangible or an
intangible benefit and a lot of the
intangible benefits it's important to
know kind of tie back to that ego or to
the knowledge side of things so a lot of
times to make it a little more clear-cut
and simple we're focused on that
tangible side you know you're sharing a
concept or you know maybe you're sharing
your Mickey ears as part
a contest or part of a campaign you know
there's something that can be associated
directly with the action that gives some
measure of positive feedback now when
you're putting your content together
keep in mind the need to integrate these
concepts together it might be that
you're putting a combination of them
together maybe you're appealing to
knowledge and ego maybe it's about
passion and ego maybe it's about ego and
reward you can have more than one of
them work together in tandem so when
building out ideas make sure that you're
keeping these traits in mind and that
you're fine-tuning your ideas based on
some of this newfound knowledge to make
sure you've got better impact hey once
you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here